こんにちははじめ社長ですいや
ドクター始めた皆さんお久しぶりだ私
ヘラクレスオオカブトを買って
育ててみますと言って早2ヶ月ほど経ち
ました世界で一番大きいと言われている
ヘラクレスオオカブトそして
責任感の背の字もない
身勝手な音がはじめ社長たくさんの人が
きっと心配されたことでしょうこいつに
生き物が育てられるのが大丈夫なのか
ヘラクレスオオカブト今どうなっているの
かそしてこの700万円の核シェルターの
中で買いますと言って今どうなっているの
か今日は最近のヘラクレスがどうなったか
も含めちょっとこのヘラクレス各
シェルター
700枚の虫かご700万円がどうなって
いるのか現状報告も含めちょっと紹介して
いきたいと思いますまさかね
こんな早いかとは思ってしまいました
見ていきましょう
[音楽]
ようこそわがラボへ
はいというわけでもともと何もなかったと
いうか普通にヘラクレスだけを買っていた
核シェルターから結構
改造してヘラクレスが
快適に生活できるつもりのヘラクレスラボ
初めて社長の
核シェルターヘラクレスロボカド
700万円が完成しました
これちょっとわざと照明とか書いてるん
ですけどもちろん普通に照明炊くとこう
いう感じであるんですけどもちょっと
LEDとか書いてねちょっといい感じにし
てみました
昆虫育てるとか虫ってなんかこうちょっと
土とかなんかこのコバエとか
匂いとかちょっとこの若干
汚いようなイメージがどうしてもきっと
みんなあると思うんですけどそういうの
ちょっと払拭したくて
綺麗な雰囲気作りもほんと研究室というか
ラボみたいな雰囲気でやりたいなと思って
ちょっと回答させていただきましたそれに
しても絶対やりすぎなんですけどね
ちょっと見てみましょうかこれは全く関係
ないんですけどなんかはじめしゃちょーの
サウナの部屋にいたカブトムシですなんか
そのまま買ってあげてますはい
ちなみに部屋の温度は今23°cですね
ヘラクレス21°cから25度が適温とさ
れていますこのラボでヘラクレス買って
から21だから25度ずっとキープして
ます完璧な状態を保ってますね
[音楽]
寒いぐらいかな今そして皆さん気になって
いるでしょう
肝心なヘラクレス剥がして生きているのか
死んでいるのか
見ていこうと思います
バチバチに元気バチバチに元気に生きて
おりますちょっと加湿ヘラクレス飼い始め
て2ヶ月経ちましたがもう元気ビンビンで
ございます
失礼し死なせてくれるかなみんなにお顔
見せてくれる今日はちょっとご機嫌斜めか
な
痛い痛いマジで痛い本当に痛い待って
やばい
[音楽]
気がしましたけれどももう変わらず元気
いっぱいですあれ
あれ
ドクターはじめはじめんさ
ヘラクレス最初買った時
背中の色黄色くなかった
ひょっとしても殺してすり替えた
違いますこれも調べて分かったんですけど
ヘラクレスのこの背中の部分あるじゃない
ですかここ今もう真っ黒だと思うんです
けれどもこのねヘラクレスの背中の色って
湿度によって変わるんですよまあ湿度だけ
じゃなくてなんか食事の栄養とかも関係
するらしいんですけど
湿度がしっかりしていると黒くなるらしい
ですでも今ねいつも検査の中は湿度
ちょっと高めなので黒くなるんですけど
しばらくこういう風にケースの外に出すと
だんだんね黄色くなってくると思うので
ちょっと開けておくのでまた後から見てみ
ましょうかはいまあなんせバチバチの元気
のいかついつのゴリゴリでございます痛い
痛いマジでやばいマジでやばい本当に暴力
暴力いやだ痛いねやだもう無理本当に手
つけれないわこの子痛いもう本当に嫌だ
痛いの
ちなみにメスも元気ですちょうど今起きて
きたねおはよう目線も元気に起きています
おはようそしてここでお知らせがあります
なんとですね
はじめヘラクです
赤ちゃん見ました
[音楽]
赤ちゃん売りましたそれも結構はいもう
薄々気づいてる人いると思うんですけれど
も後ろ結構
充実してるんですよこれもね幼虫が生まれ
てきてもいいようにこういうケースをもう
先に買ってありますもういつでも入れる
ように土も入れてありますもうちょっと
ほんと湿度を高めないといけないんです
けど今何もいないんですけども
幼虫用のお部屋をもう準備してやります
今回はどっちかというとこのお部屋とか
ラボ現状の説明なのであんまりちょっと
深くは話さないんですけど
すごいそんなにうまくいくんだったけど
あの卵バキバキに産んじゃってバキバキっ
ていう表現だったのかわかんないんです
けどまたちょっと発表させてください今日
は卵に関してあんまり話さないんですけど
ちょっとどんだけどんだけ産んだのみたい
なちょっと最終的にどれだけ読んだかまた
ちょっと別の動画で報告させていただき
ますただ現在進行形で卵を産んでいますで
ヘラクレス買ってて気づいたんですけれど
もこんだけ閉鎖空間
デジタルの中で育てていてもコバエコバエ
からはねもう逃げられませんでしたどうし
てもコバエが湧いてしまうのでこういうね
コバエ駆除用のなんか照明みたいなの買い
ましたこれすごいんですよなんか光につら
れてコバエが来て近づくとバチって
駆除できるっていうそしてほら背中
乾燥してきたからちょっと黄色くなってき
ましたねそうヘラクレスの背中ってね
湿度で変わるのよ背中の色がはいという
感じでヘラクレスは無事に生きています
そしておめでたで子供も生まれましたこの
ヘラクライナですからですね交尾する瞬間
も映像として撮れたし卵が初めて見つかっ
た瞬間も動画に撮ってますここ最近作業
やってたことを動画にしてるのでぜひご覧
くださいどうぞ
ちゃんと食べてるちゃんとパクパク食べて
ますよかったよかった一方メスはもうね
ずーっと食べてるのよねはいこんな感じ
ですちょっと狭いな本当に大きくして
あげるいつか近いうちにちょっと大きくし
てあげようずーっと食べてるな
[音楽]
はいなんと
ます買って1週間ぐらいで卵ができました
早くね最初の店の卵って無精卵であること
が多いらしくてそもそもこれがまだ
幼虫ができるかわからないのと感想だけ
本当にしちゃダメらしいのでとりあえず卵
別の容器に移し替えますメスを探します今
だって卵を産んでるって事でしょ
邪魔はしたくないんですけどこの子の安全
のため
移したいんですよ見てくださいみなさん
また卵を見つかりました
卵2個あるこここことここにもう
完全に始まってるなぁメスだけ一応避難さ
せますねごめんな疲れてるのかこの子は
ちょっとしばらくここで卵を産んでもらい
ますそもそもこれがその腰痛が帰る卵か
どうかもわかんないのでとりあえず今
ピックアップしたっていう感じです
卵産んでから約1か月ぐらい経ったので
ちょっと様子見たいと思いますよし探して
いきましょう見落としたりすると怖いよね
うんなんか大きくなってる気がする大きく
なってるよね
なんか結構大きくなってる気がする
繰り返すぞ
[音楽]
でかい
ね
ちょっと待ってください
要注意
やばい赤ちゃんできてた赤ちゃんできてい
たというので無事に帰った幼虫が今ここに
6匹いますはいこれとかも見えそうだけど
ないやこれはちょっともうちょっと大きく
なってからも楽しみですねちゃんとラベル
派っていつ
孵化したかもなんとなくでいいので書いて
ありますヘラクレスの幼虫が成虫になる
まではもう1年半とか2年とかかかったり
すると言われてるので多分ね来年とかは
ワンちゃん生まれないと思うんですよ結構
長期の
育成になると思われますただまだ卵を産み
続けてるので今後どれだけ増えたかとか
ちょっとまた身長があったら動画にしよう
と思いますのでちょっとそこは楽しみにし
ててください多分なんですけどいやいや
はじめお前こんなに準備してどうすんだ
よって思います
余裕で足りないぐらいだと思うんですよ何
個産んだかとかちょっとお楽しみにしてて
欲しいんですけどヘラクレス卵のため弱
るっていう話を聞いたので多分この
オスメスももうそんな長くないかもしれ
ないのでメスとかも
産んでからすぐなくなっちゃうという話も
聞いたことあるので一段落してから
ちょっと腰痛どんだけ生まれたのかとか
動画にしたいと思いますもう別々で買って
一緒の部屋入れて1週間放置してたら卵
できてましたマジでスピードこんいや
こいつらに結婚って概念はないんですが
結構ねヘラケースってそのペアリング交尾
させるとペアリングって言うんですけど
なかなかうまくいかない時とかもある
らしいんですけども自然にもう一瞬で多分
これ出会って
即日かなりの速さで交尾から完了して
卵が生まれたっていう感じですはい
というわけでヘラクレスラボいかがだった
でしょうか前にも言ったんですけれども
ぶっちゃけ生き物なので何が正しいかとか
この育て方が正しいとかそういうのはない
んですよそんなヘラクレスによりますから
ただ間違いなくヘラクレスのオスとメスが
この環境で
快適に生活しそして卵も驚きの1週間以内
に海そして
幼虫が生まれたこの現実を見る限り多分
いい環境なのかなとは思いましたここから
ちょっとどうなるかわかんないしちょっと
した何かで
昆虫って死んじゃったりするのでこの先
どうなるかわかりませんがあのこの
ヘラクレスのフィギュアすごいでしょこれ
フィギュアなのよヘラクレスのフィギュア
とかも監修されてる広丘さんていう
ちょっとヘラクレスのもうなんか日本代表
みたいな方がいらっしゃってそういう方
ともちょっとね連絡を見ずに取り合い
ながらいろいろアドバイスを受けつつ
ちょっと引き続きこの隠したヘラクレス
ラボより強化していきたいと思います
卵の数はマジですごいですよただあの無精
卵と有精卵って言って卵だけど生まれてこ
ない無性卵とかもあるし全部が有精卵と
いうことはまずないので
卵の数だけ幼虫が生まれることもないん
ですけどもちょっと最終的に何匹になるの
か子供は何匹産むことができるのかお
楽しみではまたヘラクレスラボでお会いし
ましょうバイバイ
[音楽]